i think it's called the mining council
uh the meeting with
elon uh that michael uh sailor put on
just whatever you can say about in terms
of like going into it kind of what was
your thought process of like
uh we're gonna participate in this i i
think you guys
um were you hoping to get out of it and
then like at the meeting i don't know
how much you can talk about like what
was actually discussed but just like
what did you get out of it right so
preface i wasn't actually on the call
okay our chairman uh okamoto was on the
call
but going into it what we really wanted
to do was
um really work with elon to help him
understand kind of what we're doing
uh you know he put out a tweet that
showed you know the carbon footprint
uh if it was all based on coal et cetera
et cetera uh
of what was happening with power
consumption and so we really wanted a
address that with him let him know kind
of what we're doing and that we are much
greener than
um you know he put out to say and then
offer the opportunity to collaborate and
um
you know while i think he tweeted after
the meeting uh a tweet that he was
uh you know going to collaborate with us
um yeah we'll have to see
kind of what he does i put out an open
invite to him yesterday on fox
you know and said hey we'd love to work
with you on the technology
right you know renewable energy is a
technology that
needs investment and continued to drive
the cost down battery storage and
utility scale storage is a
huge opportunity that will benefit every
single consumer in north america and
around the world
and the bitcoin mining industry could
fund a lot of that because it's helpful
to what we're doing
so i would love to collaborate with them
and any other technology providers in
that space
yeah um i forget who said it but
somebody said the use of the word
counsel right was probably too uh
not thought out enough right and like
maybe association would have given a
different uh
inclination to it yeah and so let's hold
that constant of like forget
nomenclature for a second
what is your understanding of kind of
like what this mining association
council whatever
uh is gonna do moving forward is it kind
of like hey we're gonna meet you know
once a quarter
and we're gonna kind of just like help
each other with best practices is it
more of uh we're gonna all publish the
same report and
with data uh do you guys have elon cell
phone number and you're gonna like you
know text
whenever something happens like like how
do you kind of just see this moving
forward yeah
i don't think we'll be texting him um
he'll tweet it you guys don't yeah
we'll copy him on a tweet or two we
might dm him but um
so you know the goal is uh really to
provide a forum if you would for any
minor
to basically come and learn and also for
us all to educate
the marketplace not just the regulators
but also the general marketplace about
what we're doing
and so part of that is going to be
publishing commitments here's what we
intend to do over the next year you know
we've publicly said that
our next deployment will be fully carbon
neutral and we'll
achieve a full carbon neutral over our
whole fleet by the end of next year
um and so we'll be held accountable to
that and you know even the small miners
uh to publish kind of you know here's
our current power footprint what
the sources we're using here's where
we're going to be and then reporting on
a regular basis
whether that's monthly or quarterly
that's to be seen but the mission is
really of education and
information sharing um it's not uh you
know i think somebody tweeted you know
oh this is opec
for mining it's not for one thing the
market share of the members
is fairly small still in the overall
global hash rate
um and it's open to anybody wants to
join uh you know the good thing about
this industry is
every bitcoin is the same we don't
control the price the market controls
the price
um so there's no product differentiation
uh and there's no pricing
differentiation so it's really
operational excellence
and it feels like uh a big
differentiation here
is that as far as i understood from what
i've read and people i've talked to
there's no like hey we're gonna come
together and make decisions
right it's more so we're going to come
together and what we're going to do
is we're going to agree from a
publishing standpoint like what con
what content what data should be shared
and it's more so
um almost like industry standards
more so than it was like let's all make
a decision
on an action that we're going to take
that has an effect on bitcoin the
blockchain
the mining process etc uh and so in some
way if people can separate out like
hey let's talk about what internal data
we should share versus like
you know some of the other meetings that
have happened to bitcoin that haven't
turned out so
uh so well like 2017 yes uh
you guys are basically doing the former
right it's like we have all this data we
understand our energy mix we understand
um you know uh so much of what each
other's doing like we should all come
out and say it because it's gonna be
overall good for the industry